[Applause]
thank you very much it's a pleasure to
be here and it's a pleasure to talk
about uh climate change uh right when
you introduced me I actually also work
on a lot of other problems together with
a lot of uh economists and and and nice
people too uh and
and I would love to talk about that as
well but that's not the talk I've been
invited to do and that's not the talk
that I have on on on the slides so I'm
going to be talking about climate but
remember and I think we'll have that
coming up in in some of the questions
there's a lot of other issues in the
world and I think one of the ways we
talk smarter about climate is also to
get people to realize most people in
this planet actually suffers from many
many other things apart from climate but
with that said uh can I get my slides up
because I'm actually I'm going to show
you a lot of data I'm I'm a statistician
right I think data is sexy
um but you know fundamentally thank you
and and that was just one guy right
so I'm gonna get out of this way as you
also heard I'm a political scientist I'm
sort of a pretend Economist uh so
um I'm not going to go into the whole
conversation on global warming I simply
take that as a granted yes there is
global warming yes it's man-made yes it
is an important problem I'll show you uh
some of the evidence on that
but that's not the main point that I'm
trying to make it is much more that a
lot of the conversation around global
warming is vastly exaggerated uh you
hear it all the time but it matters a
recent survey always of oecd countries
so all the rich countries in the world
uh showed that now about 60 percent
of all people in the rich countries
believe that global warming will likely
or very likely lead to the end of
mankind
now if that's really true then that's
obviously terrible I mean this is really
something that means people are worried
sick it's not just uh youngsters anymore
it really is everyone who thinks this is
a terrible thing that's coming at us and
that's of course why we need to do
everything in our power to deal with it
that makes perfect sense I don't know if
you uh remember when AOC was talking
about this back in 2018
um she she we
but I and I think in some ways it's
important to understand where this comes
from because if you think this is the
end of the world it actually makes
perfect sense what she said and many
others you know I I live in Sweden now
where uh Greta tunberg lives uh and and
I I think I think it makes sense to
realize if you think this is the end of
the world if you think this is a meteor
hurtling towards Earth
there's really no other thing that you
should be concerned about right the only
thing if this was a meteor huge meter
that's going to eradicate all of human
humankind the only thing we have to do
is to get Bruce Willis and the guys out
of you know retirement and get up and do
something about that right right so the
the truth here is unless we get to
understand this is not the end of the
world We're not gonna have this the rest
of the conversation sensible and so I'm
getting back to the AOC uh uh Point she
said back in 2018 when a lot of people
told you told us we had 12 years left to
save the planet she said and I think it
makes sense she said
we have 12 years left to save the planet
and you're worried about how much it's
going to cost
that makes sense if this is the end of
the world we should just spend
everything
I want to show you why this is not the
end of the world it's a problem not the
end of the world and that matters a lot
so let me show you some of these slides
so first of all
you've all heard this but I just want to
you know sort of set the stage this is
uh guteris uh the secretary's general of
the U.N but almost every Western leader
uh and many others will mimic these
sorts of claims he'll tell you the world
is facing a grave climate emergency
every week brings new climate-related
Devastation floods droughts uh heat
waves wildfires Super Storms uh we're in
a battle for our lives and climate
change is the biggest threat to the
global economy I think this is stories
that we can all uh recognize we hear
them constantly in our news feeds and it
certainly is uh what the current
Administration many uh around the world
is also saying this is an existential
threat this really is the question about
whether you and especially your kids
will be able to survive in this world
and again that's the Gambit of saying
hence we should pay up anything this
will cost but let's just get a sense and
I'm just going to take you through a few
of these I'd like to talk for about 35
more minutes and then we'll have plenty
of time for Q a
Gutierrez many others talk about these
super storms that we're all going to be
uh hit by terrible uh hurricanes well
what do we actually know if you ask the
UN climate panel and again I take the
starting point here I think they are
actually please don't read them it's
like 4 000 pages is incredibly boring
but they're actually pretty good uh most
of the stuff if you look at what they
say about the past is that fundamentally
we have very very little knowledge about
it identifying past Trends in tropical
Cyclones as they call hurricanes remains
a challenge we have low confidence and
most reported long-term trends I'm going
to show you the one that we do actually
have confidence in and in the future
they expect that we're going to see more
strong hurricanes which is a problem
we're also probably going to see few
total hurricanes which is a good thing
but it turns out when you add those two
things overall fewer hurricanes but
stronger hurricanes means that it's
going to be worse overall so this is one
of of the many reasons why global
warning is a real problem it is a
problem but it's not the end of the
world and let me just show you that so
if we look for instance on hurricanes
for U.S we have some of the longest
statistics for the U.S again if you look
out in the middle of the ocean there
were no satellites back in 1900 right so
you don't know what happened out there
but we do know that land falling
hurricanes were very likely to have been
observed at least since 1900 so we have
a good record of how many land-falling
hurricanes have there been in the U.S
since 1900 it turns out that the number
is slightly declining it's not
increasing contrary to what you hear and
then when people say but surely we see
more and more strong hurricanes well
actually if you look at the same thing
for major hurricane 3 category three and
above the the same thing again slightly
declining not increasing
Point here is the data tells you
something else than what the common
story is
if you think about it it makes good
sense it's a little bit the same thing
as if you if you looked at what happened
at least for the last 30 years in the
U.S the FBI statistics for about 30
years maybe not the last couple years
showed
strong decline in all crime in the U.S
yet every year when Gallup asked people
every year people said there's more and
more crime
and that's true where is there more and
more crime there's more and more crime
on TV right this is the CNN effect right
it's essentially the fact that we have
replaced seeing once a you know a day
that there was some crime now we can see
it wall-to-wall on all channels all the
time you're not well informed if you
take your statistics from just watching
more and more cable news and this is
essentially the same thing we're doing
when we're hearing more and more about
hurricanes we're hearing more and more
about all kinds of weird weather it's
not surprising because nobody takes
cameras out and say I'm out here and
Reporting and there's nothing nothing
has happened right it's always something
happening right and that's of course why
we get scared uh let me show you uh so
uh sorry I should just also mention we
actually have good data I just showed
you the one for the us but if we look at
the world we have good data satellites
uh and and if you look at the total
hurricane energy
actually last year 2022 was the second
lowest ever
did you hear that anywhere no because
that's not a fun story right that's this
I'm hearing there's nothing to you you
don't do that it's no fun but it's not a
good way to inform us actually we
believe that in the future hurricanes
will be worse overall global warming
will be a problem but it's not what
we're seeing in the statistics and we
need to show this both to our kids they
stop being scared witness but also to
everyone else to realize this is not an
end of the world situation let me show
you one other thing and I I've just
shown you Wildfire This Is Such Great
Clips right I mean who who don't want to
click on this
but again we're constantly being shown
pictures of places where it burns not
where it doesn't burn do you guys
remember
um uh the the big forest fires in
Australia and uh 2019-20
uh
after that had happened I actually went
back because we have satellite coverage
for this and what it turned out was
there was enormously much fire
close to where news crews live that is
you know Sydney and Melbourne but
actually overall for Australia it was
one of the lowest burned years of fire
ever
you well informed if you only saw what
the guys in Sydney and Melbourne saw no
that's again the whole point we need to
look at the statistics so let me show
you if you look at Global fire we have
pretty good data since 1900 this is
model data but it's data that is used by
the U.N climate panel to feed into the
climate models and what we've seen is
about uh in early 1900 about 4.2 percent
of the world's surface burnt every year
and since then what you see is it's
actually been declining
very contrary to what you probably have
heard
but now we have satellite data
satellites across the the world all the
time discover where does it burn so we
have much better data and this is what
they show for the last you know 25 years
a dramatic decline this is something
that science and nature and everybody
else has written about but it's not what
you see right you see more and more fire
in the TV
despite the fact that this is what the
data tells you and if you look out into
the future what is likely to happen if
we do nothing about climate well we'll
probably see even less fire now if we
have strong climate policy we will see
even less fire
so yes there is a point here but it's
not that the world is going to burn up
as New York Times uh love to point out
but it is a fact that we have seen less
and less fire in the world and if we do
for instance climate policy we can see
even less but it's not that the whole
world is burning up again we need to
know these facts why is it declining
because most people don't like fire so
we actually actively try to suppress
fire we try to avoid fire we're a smart
species
but you know again we seem to forget
this very often now I would actually
argue that's probably one of the reasons
why we have a really hard time having a
sensible conversation about climate
because we only talk about what Will
climate do but not what will humans do
so that's my point in saying basically
we miss adaptation let me show you uh
what happens here if you look at deaths
from climate uh from we have pretty good
data over the last hundred years how
many people die from climate so that
would be floods drought storms wildfires
and extreme temperatures
it turns out that a hundred years ago in
the 1920s on average about 500
000 people died each and every year on
average this is a very very fluct
trading so I'm taking the average per
decade since then you know if you listen
to The Climate sort of alarmism you'd
imagine that it's just gone up and up
you can kind of see it doesn't because
I've already set the the the chart up
here right but what it does
is it
incredibly decline over the last hundred
years in the 2010s the average number of
people dying from climate related
disasters Was Eighteen thousand these
will last three years so 2020 21 and 22.
these are the years that you constantly
hear about oh my God all people are
dying and yes
in 2022 there were 11 000 people dying
we certainly heard about some some of
them in news we also didn't hear about a
lot of them about a thousand of them
were from Indian floods that you've
probably never heard of
but the important point is when you
count all of them they're much much
smaller today than they used to be 100
years ago again why
because we're rich
because we're much smarter we have much
better prediction we have much better
technology we're much better able to
avoid people dying from these disasters
it has nothing to do with climate it has
everything to do with the fact that
we're much better able to adapt and of
course this also sends an important
message to how do you want to help
people to avoid these kinds of problems
in the future you do that by making sure
that they're rich that they're able to
deal with these issues that they're able
to be resilient in the face of natural
catastrophes